Halloween sees the return of mutant mass
murderer Michael Myers a complete retcon
of the last 40 years of film the movie
places the madman in an asylum where he
has remained since the 1978 original
film after breaking free the serial
killer wrecks havoc once more in an
attempt to kill Laurie Strode however
she is no longer the quivering girl that
she was in the original movie there's a
lot to unpack from the film's ending and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the ending of Halloween and full detail
so there will be heavy spoilers with
that out the way I'm definition and I
ruin the movie so you don't have to
after murdering five people on Halloween
in 1978 Michael Myers has been behind
bars Laurie Strode played by Jamie Lee
Curtis is conscious of the fact that one
day he will escape so she spent the last
40 years preparing and training for his
return upon being transferred to another
prison Michael escapes and returns to
the town to finish the work that he
started four years ago we discover that
he was freed by doctor Sartain in order
to continue his rampage Sartain was the
successor to dr. Loomis and wanted to
see how Michael would react after
struggling to gain any insight into his
condition he allowed two podcasters to
bring Michael his mask to get a rise out
of him and wanted to provoke the killer
to react and remember his original
attack Sartain wanted to see Michael
tick and whilst we never get a complete
explanation for his actions I believe
that he spent so long in the madhouse
that he became mad himself constant
exposure to the insane and killers seems
to have vastly affected his psyche and
sautèing struggle to view the world is
simply more than patients sautéing
clearly admires Michael and when he
becomes a killer himself tries on the
mask to see if he can get a glimpse into
his
world this proves futile however and the
character is eventually murdered which
to me symbolizes that Sartain normal
walk would never be able to see and
understand things from the killer's
perspective in the mid section of the
film Michael goes on a rampage and
several people are murdered before he
and Laurie finally face off against each
other their final showdown contains a
lot of Easter eggs and callbacks to the
original movie such as the two facing
off in the same room that had the
cupboard seen in the original as well as
Laurie disappearing when wounded which
juxtaposes when Michael did it in the
past during the confrontation Laurie
manages to trap Michael in a safe room
with help from Karen and Alison her
daughter and granddaughter respectively
in preparation for his return Laurie
fortified her house and built a safe
room into it which had bars and
blockades that could be put in place to
stop people entering it throughout the
film karen has been acting weak and
defenseless in order to paint herself
out as an easy target the two used
themselves as bait in order to lure
Michael to the panic room and when he's
forced into it Laurie uses the
opportunity to trap him down there
Laurie fills the safe room with gas
before throwing a flare into it to set
it ablaze
Michael apparently dies within the
burning building and we watch as a three
survivors embrace as they go to safety
what I love about the film is that it
references the original in several
intelligent ways whilst films like the
force awakens or straight-up remakes
this is a remake in an evolved sense as
Michael Myers is purposely trying to
relive the night of the first film
things such as Alison being in school
and looking out the window to see Laurie
there before she disappears a detail
down to the fact that Alison is even
attending the same lesson that Laurie
was in the 1978 film the Easter eggs in
every scene are simply astounding and I
definitely recommend that you go back
and check out the original as it will
paint this film in a better light
so what did you think of the ending of
Halloween did you enjoy it and do you
think Michael Myers will return what's
your favorite Halloween movie is it
Halloween Halloween or Halloween yeah
they do need to kind of rename these
movies anyway comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel you love our weekly
videos if you're a fan of film and it
massively helps us out make sure you
check out my ending explained video for
the Netflix film called the dark linked
at the end of this one and thanks again
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]